ja Herr Karl lassen Sie uns gerne
einfach damit einsteigen also es gibt
jetzt diese Meldung dass die Ukraine in
ihrer gegen Offensive offenbar deutliche
Fortschritte macht wie sieht es ihre
Einschätzung nach aktuell aus an der
Front
ja also auch das sind unsere
Erkenntnisse dass sich nach acht Wochen
nun eine eine andere Strategie wohl
durchsetzt eine andere Taktik in
Operationen der Ukrainer man hat
wahrscheinlich seine Lehren auch
ausgezogen zumindest erkennbar dass nun
anders vorgegangen wird und die ist auch
erfolgreich absolviert wurde im Moment
Herr Karl lassen Sie uns gerne einmal
schauen wir haben eine Karte auf der man
das glaube ich ganz gut einmal
verdeutlichen kann und das auch gut
erkennt also diese Fortschritte bzw die
Stellen an denen die ukrainischen
Truppen gerade offenbar die russischen
Besatzer deutlich unter Druck setzen das
ist einmal bei der Stadt und im Gebiet
dann nett bei welica kam das sehen wir
jetzt hier gut auf der Karte bisher hieß
es ja immer sie haben es gerade schon
gesagt in den vergangenen acht Wochen so
richtiges Vorankommen ist da irgendwie
nicht was ist jetzt auf einmal anders
also nach unseren Erkenntnissen haben
die Ukrainer ihre Erfahrungen gesammelt
in den ersten Wochen haben selber
mitbekommen und das war ja auch in den
Medien
nachvollziehbar das Vorgehen war relativ
langsam aber nun hat man die Taktik
geändert also das Vorgehen in Gruppen
verspricht doch mehr Erfolg als die
vorhergehende Taktik die angewandt wurde
nehmen Sie mich da gerne einmal ein
bisschen mit also sie sagen dass das
vorangehen in Gruppen wie muss man sich
sozusagen die Taktik vorher vorstellen
und wie sieht sie jetzt aus wenn Sie das
vielleicht einmal ein bisschen ausführen
können
sie haben ja die Karte auch vorliegen
wenn Sie die russischen stellungssysteme
die ja auch bei anderen Think Tanks auch
zu lesen sind und auch die Karten die
man da studieren kann dann stellt man
doch fest dass die russischen
Streitkräfte ein umfassendes
stellungssystem
gespickt mit vielen Minenfeldern
aufgebaut haben hier hat man
Erkenntnisse gewonnen und geht nun
anders vor heißt also gegenseitige
Deckung
raubartiges vorgehen bzw überschlagendes
Vorgehen
man nutzt auch
Militärgerät wo man Minenfelder
unschädlich machen kann bzw Gassen
hineinspringen kann umso besser
vorzukommen also
es ist fast natürlich in Kriegen das in
einer Konfliktsituation Erkenntnisse
gewonnen werden und wenn man nicht voran
konnte da muss man etwas ändern und das
hat die Ukraine gemacht und die
ukrainische Armee
hier ein Vorteil dass die russischen
Streitkräfte fest sind in ihren
Stellungen das heißt die Flexibilität
ist beim Angriff der ukrainischen Kräfte
und Sie können natürlich entsprechend
variieren und das ist hier gerade der
Fall
über die Minenfelder die es auch in der
Vergangenheit den ukrainischen Truppen
schwer gemacht haben vorzurücken
sprechen wir auch noch im Laufe dieses
Streams auch gerne noch einmal sie uns
gerade angesprochen die Verfassung der
russischen Truppen wenn wir noch einmal
wirklich vielleicht die Karte in den
Blick nehmen die wir gerade gesehen
haben warum sind es gerade diesen diese
beiden Orte bzw auch dieses Gebiet dabei
Donut das ist eben gerade da den
ukrainischen Truppen wirklich macht da
weiter vorzudringen wieso schaffen sie
es gerade da
ja wir haben da eine
einen besonderen Blick auf die
russischen Großverbände die dort
eingesetzt worden sind oder derzeit
eingesetzt werden zum einen ist das die
58ste Armee und wir wissen ja aus den
Medien vor einigen Wochen dass der
Kommandeur general Ivan Popov ein sehr
populärer ein sehr beliebter Kommandeur
bei seiner Truppe ist durch seine
Offenheit
abgesetzt worden also das hat auf jeden
Fall schon mal Auswirkungen auf
Motivation und gefechtswert der
russischen Truppen bzw der Soldaten der
58 Armee
wobei da noch hinzukommt dass diese
Armee schon über Wochen in diesem
gefechtsabschnitt eingesetzt worden ist
und vielleicht noch einen mittleren bis
niedrigen Kampf Wert hat und jetzt
natürlich durch die Absetzung ihres
beliebten Kommandos noch zusätzlich
weniger Motivation hat dort zu kämpfen
bei der zweiten durchbruchsabschnitt
oder möglichen durchbruchsabschnitt der
fünften Armee handelt es sich um Teile
die aus allen Teilen des militärbezugs
Süd und Ost zusammengezogen worden sind
als eine Truppe die mehr oder weniger
zusammengewürfelt wurden ist auch da ist
es schwierig
ein Kampf fährt so hochzusetzen wie ein
eingespieltes Team eine Armee die von
Grund auf aufgebaut worden ist sondern
hier handelt es sich wirklich um eine
zusammengewürfelt Armee nach unseren
Erkenntnissen
kann man daraus dann schlussfolgern dass
sozusagen der aktuelle Erfolg der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte
von der Schwäche ein Stück weit ist es
ja auch logisch der der russischen
Kräfte profitiert
ja da gehen wir von außen also genau
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte oder das
Hauptquartier das Headquarter
entsprechend eruiert hat da sind die
Schwachpunkte der russischen
Streitkräfte im gesamten System und dort
greifen wir an also man darf ja auch
nicht vergessen dass die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte in der ersten Phase der
Angriffsbewegung etwa 25% ihrer Verbände
erst eingesetzt hat die Reserven sind
weitaus höher und können natürlich jetzt
mit Nachdruck auch eingesetzt werden
dazu passt sehr gut eine Frage die wir
bekommen haben bei Youtube von gähn
wegtreten welche Truppen und in welcher
Stärke sind denn an dem Durchbruch
beteiligt bzw welche Aufgabengebiete
hatten die und wie hoch sind hier
Verluste an Personal und Material
vielleicht schauen wir uns erstmal den
ersten Teil der Frage an also haben sie
Erkenntnisse darüber welche
Truppen und in welcher Stärke an diesen
ja Fortschritten jetzt gerade beteiligt
sind
also es sind die klassischen Elemente
des landkrieges die eingesetzt werden
also hier sind es Panzer und
Infanterie Verbände die eingesetzt
werden gleichzeitig in Kombination mit
Unterstützung durch Pioniereinheiten und
durch Artillerie Einheiten
die Stärke kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen
und das entzieht ja auch meiner Kenntnis
aber wenn Sie einen Angriff dort
durchführen dann sind das die Visionen
die da eingesetzt werden also in einer
Stärke von ca zwischen 10 und 12.000 pro
division
kann man das ins Verhältnis setzen wie
hoch aktuell das war ja auch ein Teil
der Frage wie hoch aktuell die Verluste
sind möglicherweise auch sozusagen im
Verhältnis bei der Seiten
also über die Verlustzahlen kann ich
nichts sagen
man geht aber immer in einer Rechnung
davon aus in einem solchen Gelände was
so anspruchsvoll ist sollte der Angriffe
Greifer eine 4 zu 1 Überlegenheit
gegenüber dem Verteidiger haben ja also
das ist die die ungefähr Berechnung die
man macht was sie Verlustzahlen angeht
so möchte ich mich darauf nicht
festlegen weil da die Zahlen auch
ziemlich ungenau sind da möchte ich
keine Aussage zu machen